in a few minutes I'll invite Alice Arab
et Manus manager and together we're
gonna talk about the update to Google
Play Instant since we launched instant
games at i/o just five months ago I'll
then invite an from small giant games
onto stage and she'll talk about her
experience developing an instant game so
Google Play instant the idea was to
really improve the user experience and
then directly have a positive impact on
developers businesses and let's start
with the user side so what is the user
experience well you click on a URL or
you click on try now and you dive into a
native experience and this allows you to
understand the game before you install
and it also gives opportunities for new
discovery experiences beyond the Play
Store and we believe this is
transformative to discovery because
playing games is the right way to
evaluate games I don't think you've ever
heard of someone saying you have to play
this game their app icon is amazing
you say you have to you have to play
this game I played it myself and it's
awesome and that's basically how you do
discovery you played the game and then
you determine do I want to spend hours
and hours playing this game into the
future this is the exact way you should
discover and we believe this is the
right evolution of the Play Store so
back in the day you had the Android
Market and you got a few beautiful icons
to assess and install then we evolved
and we said okay what if we brought some
of the strengths of Google to the Play
Store personal recommendations better
search a way for us to go deeper into
the catalog as a user and discover more
and more of what is possible on Android
and more recently we launched the play
games app which was our first foray into
content first experiences or you saw
pre-roll videos and starting to see the
content that you'll get once you install
but the future of the Play Store is
where it is purely content first where
you get to play the game first and then
install and that is the future and that
is what Google Play Instant provides the
Play Store and we're really excited
about this because this is not a new
playbook there's been precedent set in
the media every time that media becomes
instant consumption goes up both the
depth of consumption as well as the
breadth we've seen it with music we've
seen it with ebooks we've seen it with
movies we've also seen it with search as
we decrease latency usage goes up and we
think that's a incredible thing for
users because they get to experience
more but also for developers and what is
possible to bring to users so that's
that's the user side let's now talk
about you the developers what isn't it
what is in it for you well with Google
Play Instant we're seeing better users
coming through your pipeline we're
seeing more installs and we're seeing
more opportunities to bring your game
onto different surfaces not just the
Play Store when you have a URL link you
can bring it to many different surfaces
and the developer community you are
responding extremely well we've just
been live for five months and this is
just a small part number of the game
developers who have adopted in that
short period of time and what we believe
is possible with Google Play Instant is
an extension of the whole developer
lifecycle it doesn't matter where you
are on your first specific game on this
lifecycle if you're a new game that
hasn't even launched use
pre-registration and use try now to
drive that new usage even ahead of
launching or it will decrease decrease
your feature development cost by trying
out new features and try now and before
you incorporate it into your installed
game testing it out and seeing if your
audience is going to respond favorably
to it or if maybe you're in the middle
your one of your games has launched and
now you're just trying to get more users
you're trying to augment your user base
so this is a mekin
to reach new users that you might have
not been able to reach in the past
because they were fearful of that
install friction or you have a mature
game and now you're thinking about how
do I bring back some of those churned
users people who have uninstalled what
type of experience can I provide them
that is a new feature a new level
something they haven't experienced yet
and it'll bring them back to your game
one thing that we have emphasized from
the get-go is that we might be a new
platform trying to drive new discovery
but we want the developer tooling to be
identical to what you have and use in
the past for android games so it's the
same game engines that you've used the
same tool chain everything is the same
and we've worked really hard to make
sure that convergence happens and what
that means is that any game that's live
as an Android game can become an instant
game we've seen it with our top grossing
games we've seen it with AR games we've
seen it with some of our large games so
if you're 350 Meg's if you're one gig
there is a path for you to become an
instant game and we've seen it with
resource strapped indie developers have
found ways to launch through instant
games and we'll get more more and more
into that in the coming slides with that
I want to invite Alistair up he's going
to talk about how you can get even more
uplift and how we have figured out ways
to decrease the developer cost as well
as you've seen instant games is designed
to be an integral part of all aspects of
your game design so any part of the
lifecycle you can have an instant game
made for it so now you can expect to
have bigger launches by reaching more
users even easier before you actually
bring your your game to the store and
then as you've seen when you already
have an existing tiger in your portfolio
why not why not bring some more vitality
to it with an instant game I think was
also important to discuss now is
surfacing and how we can do that in the
store and how there's different areas
for you the developer to show your
instant game so some of you here today
you're already going to be looking
instant games and hopefully all of
you're going to be looking into by the
end of this presentation
but I think it's important that you
should understand from the get-go that
the try night button is really only
scratching the surface of what the
opportunity here is these various
placements and collections on the
Playstore and then of course yours the
all-important store listing page where
you can work to really drive conversions
on your page by having users to try your
game before they download it then
there's the Play games arcade in the
play games app and this is a brand new
surface where you're able to showcase
your instant game and allow users to try
it and then of course is the the old
adage of social linking in virality why
not have the option of letting new years
to share invites and invitations to
clients for example with their friends
and family I think what's really
interesting is that we've been working
very hard to expand instant games into
new areas such as premium and
pre-registration as some of you here
will know the premium games was
previously just a screenshot and a video
in your store listing page but now we're
very proud to say that you have the
option of adding an instant game to this
and once what's super important and very
exciting here is this can really
increase your store conversion rate that
you're giving the user the opportunity
to try the game before they actually
commit to purchasing that and I think
that that's really important as this
lowers the crucial entry barrier to your
title and also gives you the developer a
real platform to showcase your premium
games and we've also worked hard on top
of that to bring some pre-launch
opportunities to instant games and
what's really exciting about this is
that you're able to create virality
right into your game by adding it to
your pre-registration before you've even
launched your game so why not why
wouldn't you take advantage of this when
you have the opportunity to drive
signups and by creating variety and
really you know let giving a first taste
and a sneak peek of your game before
it's even in the store and I think this
is going to be really integral going
forward when you want to have a big
launch and really create excitement and
hype about your titles and I think
looking forward this is also very
important is it coming this quarter we
have the ambition to launch the games
room in the play games app and this is
really exciting as this will give users
a similar experience to what they know
before was something browsing YouTube
videos for instance but obviously with
instant games so this will be in an
immersive experience and it allowed the
users to seamless
switch from game to game in the games
room not compromising on the game
quality or the user experience at all
and you may be wondering how we managed
to do that
so as we roll this out you will see that
instant games funnily enough given the
instant in this title is actually how it
moves from game to game and we write to
say that this is due to a new feature
that allows us to preload the subsequent
games coming creating a seamless
experience and making sure that you the
developer don't have to compromise on
the instant game and the instant
experience that you've worked so hard to
create so I think we can both agree know
the instant games and the opportunities
offers it's pretty incredible and
there's a variety of applications that
you can do with your instant games now
and this is only growing and we're
working hard to make even easier for you
to develop these games in-house so if
you can cast your mind back a little
while to i/o you may remember that we
announced the unity beta program and
that the unity plugin was available in
github well today any unity developer
can easily create an instant game and
implement on our store and we're very
happy to say that the plug-in is
available in the unity asset store and
given the ease of this development we're
seeing significant adoption from Unity
developers with roughly 50% of the newly
published innocent games being unity
based and this is a similar story for
cocos2d at i/o we announced the alpha
version and today this is fully launched
and the IDE experience for Coco's
instant games is phenomenal with a
dragon select feature and given the fact
that Coco's is used by around 20% of
developers this really is great news
so you've seen our commitment to
developing and innovating instant games
and making it easier for you the
developer to develop your own games but
we believe this is an incredible
opportunity this should be open to every
single developer regardless of size
engineering capacity or even your
technical ability so I've shown you ways
that you as a developer using your own
current tooling are able to easily
launch and implement your own instant
games however some of you simply might
not have the resources to commit to
development today and you're not alone
we've heard this from a lot of
developers fortunately we're seeing a
growing ecosystem of agencies such as
the ones here who you can work with to
develop an instant game
so if you don't have the development
resources you don't have to worry you're
not gonna miss out you can work with
these agencies to develop your own
instant game and what's exciting here is
the agencies like this our user
acquisition and attribution experts so
they really know what they're doing and
they know how to drive installs to your
titles Jam City is just one example of
many developers have you seen that are
utilizing agencies like this in order to
create a unique instant experience as we
go forward Google plays we're gonna work
as hard as we can to implement and
invest more in our game engines and work
harder to make sure that we can really
push forward the discovery of your
instant games on the Play Store we're
gonna work incredibly hard to make sure
that we give you the best opportunity to
innovate on this amazing technology and
we really are super excited to see where
you're going to take this next now I'm
gonna pass you back to Jonathan he's
going to take you through some of the
impact the instant games can have for
you in a little bit more detail so hello
I get to come back on stage just to talk
about our successes which is great and
talk about numbers so let's dive into
that if you look at the top game
developers grossing game developers 50%
of them have already launched an instant
game so as I mentioned earlier on
adoption is really taken off and we're
really excited to see these numbers
again in just five months of being live
and then if you look at just this week
so I just had to create the slide
because I didn't even realize it until
last night there all these games just
started launching just this week so
additional game developers that have
launched includes Sega outfit seven
ncsoft in O games and Double Down so
we're really excited just to see that
we're at we believe we're at this
inflection point right now I think app
on board alone launched eight games this
week so we're really excited to see all
the adoption that's happening for
instant games and I took you through the
different life cycle different life
cycles and how you can take advantage of
instant games at each point and we've
already seen this done with by Scully
Scully has basically converted their
portfolio of games in
insolent games so if you see four
pre-registrations they use Looney Tunes
mayhem to use it for pre-registrations
before they even launched and then four
games that are just in the growth phase
like weal fortune and Walking Dead they
wanted to augment the user base so they
focused on try now and driving that ver
allottee and then for they're more
mature game like Yahtzee they decided
that they were going to try to bring
back churn users by showing an
experience that really excites the user
who might have uninstalled it to get
back into installing Yahtzee for the
pre-registration this is our first
example of using trying out for
pre-registration and we already drove
20% of the installs for or sorry 20% of
the pre registrations were from instant
games and the conversion once you landed
in an instant game was 53% to pre
registration and this is a baseline we
haven't even optimized that these
numbers yet so we're really excited to
see this and as we tune this we expect a
53% number to increase significantly but
we also expect that as users start
understanding what try now means and
what the experience is going to be
you'll start seeing click-through rates
increasing such that 20% can increase as
well
now we're also seeing better users
coming out the other end of instant
games so for Jam City cookie Jam last
they saw a 32% increase in day 7
retention for users who installed after
playing the instant game versus just the
normal organic installations and what
about monetization well played it cause
House of fun saw 48 percent increase in
revenue per install if the user had come
through an instant game versus if they
came through an organic installation and
for the indie developers in the audience
I think this is a huge value proposition
for an indie developer you've focused on
a quality game and you might but you
might not have the same brand
recognition or same marketing dollars as
some other game developers so usually
what happens when a user clicks try now
for an indie game developer or an indie
game is they're pleasantly surprised
because you've invested in that quality
of game
so they click on it and they end up
installing at a high rate we've seen
this with gun gun having a 20% increase
in user acquisition jungle adventures to
having it almost 9 percent increase in
user acquisition and bubble shoot pet
having an 8 percent increase in user
acquisition well I obviously am excited
about google play and sing cuz I'm the
product manager for it but I really
think that you would benefit by hearing
about how a game developers actually
used instant games and develop for it so
I'd like to invite Ann vu from small
giant games to talk about her experience
with Google Play and sing thank you
hello hi I'm Ann I'm the director of
performance marketing at small giant
games we are a company based in Finland
and have launched three games including
empires and puzzles a top 10 grossing
game in a hundred countries including
the u.s. we also won the Best
Breakthrough hit award by Google Play
earlier this year so today I'm going to
talk to you about how we use data to
build our instant game what works for us
and what didn't and some recommendations
going forward conversion or organic
conversion benchmark for the average RPG
game is that eight percent on Google
Play that means that over ninety percent
of users who land at the app page do not
download and we know that through
continuous a be testing that App Store
optimization can only move the needle a
little bit optimizing the app store
conversion is especially crucial when
running high budget UI campaigns 70% of
our UI budget goes towards driving
traffic to the Google Play Store so that
we knew that we had to optimize the
store conversion rate beyond just ASO
testing the used acquisition funnel has
a lot of friction at every step of the
way but the bridging the gap between
decision and action was really key for
us in optimizing use acquisition
acquisition when we introduced playable
ads compared to video ads we saw a
hundred percent
170 percent more insults and we saw that
the click-through rate or the click to
install rate improved by 38 percent thus
increasing the overall efficiency of our
UI campaigns by 25 percent encouraged by
our results we were encouraged to take
this experience and try to scale it as
much as possible how can we get as many
users to be hooked by the to this game
and under a minute as possible and this
was around the time that Google Play
introduced instant games we were we saw
the opportunity when they introduced the
unity plugin so we decided to make the
instant game available to all users the
question was how to distill this
multifaceted game of baseball ding hero
collecting match 3 and PvP into a single
memorable experience that's when we use
our performance data to collect our
experience to build an instant game we
partner with the external developer
called say PA games to build what we
want to be a streamlined optimized but
fun instant game experience and
analyzing the data we took away some key
learnings first of all don't don't cut
corners in this first example here we
saw that having a non optimized tutorial
does not convert users very well because
it left users feeling confused and
frustrated on not how knowing how to
play the game we solved we solved this
problem later on by scaling down the
game board so that it's easier but that
didn't work out well either because the
players dismissed it as being too simple
and too basic and then the final step
was getting the right mix of a immersive
experience that's complex enough to hold
the users attention as well as
streamline enough to play without a long
tutorial we also tested to see the
visual appeal of the game we found out
that the player prefer
battling a dragon over a random shark
with knives walking on the beach
so getting the visual appeal of it was
just as important as getting the
mechanic right
we tested many different levels and
bosses and we found that experimenting
with the difficulty rate or the win rate
was very important in getting their
users to convert our hypothesis was that
if a user loses he'll be more likely to
download the game and try to beat it so
we create two versions of every single
level we've made a hard one and an easy
one and we surprisingly the easy one was
more effective in converting users to
download building on the complexity of
the game we wanted to create a meta game
for the experience so we moved away from
a randomized sequence to a more coherent
saga map much like the real game and
this this experience here saves your
progress so if you play two levels and
then you don't install it the next time
that you interact with the instant game
it will take you to the boss at level 3
overall we experimented with over 30
different versions to find the right
complexity length difficulty and visual
appeal of the game so if you want to get
started I would recommend finding
finding a developer who's experienced in
game design and who has the technical
know-how to build many different ideas
and concepts and iterate on those ideas
to collect data using that data then you
can kind of find the right length
complexity visual appeal and difficulty
to build your game you don't want to cut
corners because you want to instantly
while the users with the first-time
experience thank you
[Applause]